Remember, the best way to support
The David Pakman Show is to grab a
membership at join Pacman dot com. It's quick.
It's easy. It feels good. And it's really,
really cheap. Particularly if you use the coupon
code 20-20 now, you'll save 66 percent. Let's hear
from some viewers and listeners. We are going
to take some calls via the David Pakman show
Dischord David Pakman dot com slash dischord.
That's d i. S c o r d. There are so many people
very, very interested in getting on and it's
hard to know where to start even. But I think
today we are going to first start with J. A from
Long Beach J. From Long Beach. Can you hear me.
OK. Everything. Yeah. What's going on, J. OK.
This is my second time calling. I pretty much
my first call was about, you know, Bernie
and it's like, well, what were his chances of
winning? That's what I ask you that before. Right.
That was a while ago. Yeah. Those ago and now.
I just I never I didn't think about the
questions. I was I was just gonna say.
I really like your show. I like it.
It's it's been a while. I remember like.
Two to three years ago. That's
when I heard it. And, uh.
It was pretty much helped me understand things
about politics, how they worked and all that. So
I'm just I'm just thanking you for
that. Beautiful. So I'm kind of nervous.
You're doing great, Jake. Thank
you for the kind words. We love it.
And it is, of course, very, very much appreciated.